Hail Caesar is the newest film by the
Coen brothers and it's about a movie
star played by George Clooney who's in
an old Hollywood production of a movie
called Hail Caesar and he gets kidnapped
and a ransom is set for his release but
that's sort of just like the plot
synopsis like the very condensed version
of what this movie is actually about and
what it's really about is hmm the Coen
brothers are uniquely different and I
mean that as a high high compliment
these guys have made another very
strange extremely original comedy that
really is hard to classify Josh Brolin
is really the lead character of this
movie and he plays sort of The Fixer the
guy who walks around on this studio and
just fixes little problems maybe it
takes a little pushing maybe a little
slapping but he gets it done and he was
so good in this movie this movie came
out very early this year but I think if
this movie came out later in the year he
would be getting Oscar buzz for his role
he is terrific in this movie so funny so
likable and who also is really great and
possibly even the standout of the entire
movie is Alden Ehrenreich he portrays an
actor who's mostly known for being the
cowboy type character he might grab a
guitar and sing a song or do some crazy
stunts but when he set in a drama and
suddenly has to sit there and give a
good performance the director played by
ray Fiennes is like holy crap this guy
sucks and it creates possibly the
funniest scene in the movie there's also
some really clever visual imagery
throughout this movie my buddy Drew who
I saw this movie with picked up on this
guy playing with his spaghetti at his
dinner twirling his spaghetti string
around like a lasso a total visual play
on spaghetti westerns there's a lot of
really great stuff like that throughout
this movie and I was really entertained
consistently it's so strange this is a
very strange movie I must stress that
it's so different and I can totally see
a lot of audience members being turned
off by this especially since one of the
audience members in my theater snored
throughout the entire thing but the
combination of good performances by
people like George Clooney Scarlett
Johansson Channing Tatum along with
really excellent writing and a great
satire on old Hollywood movies and how
they were made along with beautiful
cinematography once again by Roger
Deakins made Hail Caesar
a
really great movie to watch and one that
does have some narrative problems maybe
what this movie is entirely based on
tone it can go from extremely hilarious
to semi serious to very odd to almost
religious and heavenly back to a somber
movie and then funny again and while
that's really entertaining and great to
see a movie so different in original it
can make the road that this movie is
traveling a little bit rocky also in
typical Coen Brothers style it ends
rather abruptly and you might not have
that feeling of closure or catharsis
that you were looking for but that's a
Coen Brothers thing and that's not
necessarily an excuse like oh it's the
Coen brothers all their movies and sort
of strangely but they do but also like
with most Coen Brothers movies if you
dig deep enough and look under the
surface you're going to find some really
cool things happening but unfortunately
that tone isn't always consistent and
this can make some scenes drag while
others are just pure gold I'm going to
give Hail Caesar a B+ it's not like
their greatest movie or anything but
it's certainly not one of their worst
either so guys I am really really
excited about something I really truly
am I've mentioned this before I talked
about it in my review for the forest I
was given the immense privilege to be
able to write my first book thanks to
the cool people at mango media who
contacted me they had an idea for a book
and they thought I was right for it and
I spent most of the latter half of last
year writing this book and it is truly a
dream come true and I have my first copy
of it in my hand right here the film
buffs bucket lists fifty movies from the
year 2000 to 2015 that I feel you should
see it also contains a foreword by my
good friend Scott mance which I was so
so truly privileged to have his writing
in this book I was so so pleased when he
agreed to do that foreword guys it's
coming out on March 5th you can
pre-order it now on Amazon the link is
in the description below it's also going
to be sold by the great people at your
nearest Barnes & Noble bookseller which
is just I it's just truly I don't know
what to say
I really can't process the fact that I'm
holding a book that I wrote and it's an
amazing dream come true also it's going
to be in tons of independent book shops
around the United States I'm so excited
about that because those are my favorite
wants to go to like I said the Amazon
pre-order link is in the description
below if you guys feel like you would
like to support me I just thank you so
much for the fact you guys have watched
my videos because of you
guys I was able to obtain one of my
dreams of writing a book and I so so
thank you for that thank you so much you
guys are the best definitely check out
Hail Caesar if you feel you'd like to
see an original film that tributes the
way old films were made you guys are the
best and stay tuned on Sunday because
I'm gonna have another hilarious 'ti
review for you guys I'm trying to do one
a week I'm really trying hard and that
is going to be for samurai cop oh my god
what a movie I can't wait to tell you
guys about that one
that movie broke me man oh my gosh you
guys are the best thank you as always
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes